next week for the fourth year in a row I  can't believe it's been four years we're  taking our show down to San Diego for  comic-con we're gonna be we're gonna be  airing a week of shows live from the  historic Spreckels theater we've got a  lot of exciting stuff planned credible  guests lined up including the cast from  the upcoming movie predator the cast  from the upcoming movie glass a reunion  of the cast from Breaking Bad and the  cast from the movie Aquaman all going to  be joining us weird stuff gonna happen  it's all happening Wednesday July 18th  through Sunday July 22nd not our usual  times also if you'd like to attend one  of our live tapings at comic-con in San  Diego go to team koco.com slash tickets  okay and we will see you next week  in San Diego  you